schönen guten tag wir sind live
mitverfolgte live und geben direkt nach
berlin wo christian lendner jetzt
bekannt gibt mit wem
sondierungsgespräche führen will
bundestagsfraktion zur politischen lage
und zu den gesprächen der letzten tage
die fdp ist als eigenständige partei
die bundestagswahl gegangen wir haben
eine inhaltliche koalitionsaussage
gemacht die fdp tritt nur in eine
regierung der mit herr ein die den wert
der freiheit stärkt und die einen echten
impuls zur erneuerung unseres landes
setzt wir orientieren uns daran wir am
meisten erwarteten kritik umsetzen kann
dabei führen wir uns in unseren
entscheidungen frei diese
koalitionsaussage gilt auch nach der
wahl darauf können die menschen sich
verlassen
grüne und fdp haben sich trotz aller
unterschiede in den vergangenen gut zehn
tagen
und diskret beraten mit union und spd
hat das militär gespräche geben der
nächste schritt ist nun einen
gedankenaustausch von einer zeit mit
der union haben wir die größten
inhaltlichen überschneidungen das hat
sich auch in unseren gesprächen
bestätigt für uns bleibt eine
jamaika-koalition eine inhaltlich
tragfähige option
allerdings werden in der öffentlichkeit
regierungs wille und geschlossenheit der
unionsparteien zitiert
die grünen haben den vorschlag gemacht
gemeinsam ein erstes sondierungsgespräch
mit der spd zu führen die grünen
unterstrichen dass für sie jamaica eine
option bleibt bekanntlich ist das bei
uns in gleicher heißt wir haben den
vorschlag eines
gesprächs wird der spd angenommen um
gemeinsamkeiten zu prüfen die unser land
nach front bin ich habe herrn scholz
eben in abstimmung mit den grünen
angeboten dass wir bereits morgen zu
einem solchen gespräch zu dritt zusammen
kommen und das wird auch passieren
da kommen jetzt in den fragen hätte
geben müssen endlich bitte
wir im richtfunk welche rolle haben die
indiskretion aus den letzten beiden
runden für diese entscheidung von ihnen
heute morgen gespielt
die haben wir zur kenntnis
herr weiner und spiegel
[Musik]
morgen in den zwei fragen einmal gab es
vor die grünen heute morgen mit ihm ihr
ergebnis bekanntgegeben haben schon mit
ihnen eine vorabsprache dass man so
auftritt erst die grünen und dann sich
als fdp und das zweite sie hatten ja mal
im wahlkampf im
bundesvorstand gesagt dass eine ampel
möglicherweise auf dauer auch die
existenz der fdp gefährden könnte
wie geht es wie steht es um diese
einschätzung bleibt bei ihrer
einschätzung dass die ampel das
möglicherweise risikoreichere
vorhaben von die fdp die zum einen herr
weiland darf ich sie versichern dass ihr
in einem regelmäßigen austausch mit
allen relevanten akteuren stehen und zum
anderen kann ich die aussage die sie
gerade
zitiert haben nicht bestätigen zu machen
nicht aus internen sitzungen der fdp
trotzdem nochmal die nachfrage ganz
unabhängig von dem was in der
gremiensitzung vor einigen wochen gesagt
worden ist sie haben gerade gesagt
präferenz nach wie vor für jamaika ist
die angriffe ihre partei die
risikoreiche variante die fdp ist eine
eigenständige partei die fdp es mit
einer inhaltlichen koalitionsaussage in
die wahl gegangen an unsere inhaltliche
koalitionsaussage fühlen wir uns nach
der wahl gebunden wir haben wahrgenommen
dass im bundestagswahlkampf über eine
ampel spekuliert wurde und dass die
unionsparteien
nachvollziehbarer weise mit sportlichem
ehrgeiz gegen die fdp mit dieser warnung
auch wahlkampf gemacht haben die fdp hat
eines in ihrer historisch besten
ergebnisse erzielt
lindner bei mir steht jetzt ein bisschen
beeindruckt wenn sie sagen sie wollen
morgen schon ein gespräch führen mit spd
und grünen
dass sie möglicherweise dann auch
schnell zu dem ergebnis kommen dass das
vielleicht doch nichts wird und dass sie
dann danach doch für jamaika und tieren
ist das ein falscher eindruck oder ist
das tatsächlich morgen nur der auftakt
fügt dann weitere gespräche die dann
wahrscheinlich in
koalitionsverhandlungen beenden werden
wir haben in unseren gremien beschlossen
dass wir schritt für schritt vorgehen
und dass wir uns jeweils auf den
nächsten schritt die nächste klärung
konzentrieren und dass wir nicht schon
abstrakte debatten über
fahrpläne und was wäre wenn szenarien
führen
das heißt es gibt morgen erstmal ein
gespräch und dann ziehen sie noch mal
schluss und
entscheiden dann wie es weitergeht ich
kann nicht mehr auf ihre nachfragen
sagen als das was ich gerade schon
ausgeführt haben wir entscheiden jeweils
schritt für schritt und schauen mit den
erkenntnissen die wir dann gewonnen
haben was ein nächster gemeinsamer
schritt sein könnte wir kommen zu herrn
kessler verlässt die deutschen seite
wie war denn die stimmung im
bundesvorstand und in der fraktion bei
diesem weiteren vor vorgehen haben das
gefühl dass viele bauchschmerzen wir
haben sorge haben diesen weg jetzt zu
geben eine ampel zu sprechen und eine
frage noch zum verhältnis zu den grünen
war das jetzt eine etappe die
abgeschlossen ist dieses besonders enge
zusammengehen mit den grünen oder wird
sie das durch die weiteren sondierung
koalitionsverhandlungen begleiten
es gab im bundesvorstand und in der
bundestagsfraktion
einmütig große unterstützung für die art
und weise der gesprächsführung der
vergangenen tage und das was ich gerade
hier dargelegt habe haben bundesvorstand
und bundestagsfraktion
einmütig begrüßt
wir werden sehen wie die nächsten wochen
monate und jahre sind aber aus der
gemeinsamen
überzeugung dass dieses land erneuert
werden muss hat sich trotz aller
unterschiede natürlich ein gemeinsames
interesse
ergeben grüne und fdp sehen viele dinge
sehr unterschiedlich wir haben aber
erfahren dass wenn wir uns um
verständigung bemühen dass dann eine art
fortschritts freundliches zentrum
gewählt werden kann
und daraus ergibt sich viel fantasie
willkommen zur nächsten frage für heute
für herrn stempel erhalten
wären mögliche spätere
sondierungsgesprächen mit der union nur
mit anlass möglich oder auch mit anderen
mit einem anderen cdu vorsetzen auf eine
solche frage kann man nur falsch
verantworten weil diese debatte von uns
zumindest ist gar nicht geführt wird
vielen dank dennoch musste hat noch
einen satz sagen weil da gab es gerade
falsche berichterstattung und
spekulation es gibt keine parallel
gespräche
führen
danke fürs kommen einen schönen tag auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
ja soweit die pressekonferenz der fdp
der vorsitzende christian lindner hat
das gerade gesagt auch die fdp will
jetzt erstmal sondierungsgespräche für
eine ampelkoalition
das heißt eine regierung aus spd grünen
und fdp darüber wollen wir reden und
zwar mit unserem
hauptstadtkorrespondenten daniel pontzen
hallo daniel ich grüße dich grüße jusos
und sie können natürlich daniel auch
ihre fragen stellen und die schreiben
sie bitte einfach in die kommentare
spalten oder schicken sie dir an die
adresse die sie jetzt hoffentlich unten
eingeblendet sehen daniel vielleicht
kommen wir noch mal kurz auf die
pressekonferenz zurück wer hat christian
lendner diese entscheidung jetzt
begründet
interessant ist völlig an dieser
pressekonferenz gerade nach
den jahr zuvor die grünen sich an die
öffentlichkeit gewandt hatte und sich
danach dann schon in diesem echtzeit
berlin dass wir in diesen tagen erleben
dann stimmen laut wurden die sagten ja
das ist ein vorpreschen der grünen
manche haben das sozusagen schon als ein
affront gegen die fdp gewertet und
dieser auftritt von christian lindner
der hat jetzt doch eher in andere
richtung gedeutet
er hat ja betont das fand ich sehr
interessant ich habe olaf scholz das
gesprächsangebot gemacht dass wir die
fdp und die grünen eben schon morgen mit
der spd dann in gespräche treten und
dass er dieses ich betont sprich dass
die fdp da ebenso zu sagen diesen
initiativen move gemacht hat deutet eben
darauf hin dass die fdp nicht nur auf
dem beifahrersitz
sitzt und dass die grünen das jetzt
nicht nicht allein entschieden haben das
war ja wie gesagt sondern erste lesart
nach den grünen pk und die tatsache dass
diese fdp pressekonferenz jetzt so lange
auf sich warten lassen hat auch den ein
oder anderen
schon in diesem gedanken bestärkt
gefühlt aber ich würde sagen nach dieser
pressekonferenz sieht es doch eher nach
einem sehr geordneten auch nach einem
abgesprochenen
prozess ab zwischen grünen und fdp ein
hinweis darauf war auch noch wie ich
fand sehr interessant ist wo der konkret
die frage gestellt ob es schon vor dem
heutigen vormittag gespräche zwischen
fdp und grünen gegeben habe
oder ob das jetzt alles so ganz
kurzfristig tatsächlich besprochen und
dann eben auch entschieden wurde und
christian lindner hat daraufhin
geantwortet dass man in zitat
regelmäßigem austausch mit allen
relevanten akteuren stehe das deutet man
hier in berlin eigentlich immer so ein
bisschen als verklausulierten hinweis
darauf dass man in der tat schon vorher
gesprochen hat rundet das ist natürlich
konkret bestätigt hat und christian
lindner hat ja auch noch mal gesagt dass
er eine jamaika regierung eigentlich
präferieren würde weil da ja die
größeren schnittmengen sind wie schwer
es der fdp diese entscheidung gefallen
im grunde hat sich würde ich sagen in
den letzten tagen alles in diese
richtung schon bewegt alles andere wäre
natürlich nach dem wahlergebnis auch
schwer zu begründen gewesen vor allen
dingen für die grünen und für die grünen
mit blick auf die eigene basis und auch
die eigene wählerschaft insofern war
schon absehbar auch nachdem gestern
armin laschet dann ja doch sehr sehr
defensiv eingeräumt hat dass man klar 22
sieger gewesen ist sozusagen bei dieser
wahl und das nun sozusagen in die ampel
zunächst sondiert wird
das waren hat sich im grunde in den
letzten tagen abgezeichnet und da wäre
es für die fdp wahrscheinlich auch
unklug gewesen da so viel widerstand zu
leisten
um jetzt seinen an richtung zu gehen
aber christian lindner hat ja auch
betont dass nicht nur er sich jamaika
als option offenhalten will sondern dass
die grünen das auch getan haben und so
war es ja auch
robert habeck hat daher
wörtlich gesagt der keks sei noch lange
nicht gegessen
was natürlich auch der taktische gründe
haben kann weil sich die grünen jamaika
als sozusagen backup auch als
verhandlungsmasse offen halten wollen
und das stärkt natürlich die position
sowohl von grün als auch fdp dann in
gesprächen mit der spd
wird man so verhandlungen also das
schwächt ja wiederum auch ein bisschen
die verhandlungsposition der spd weil es
sieht eher ein bisschen so aus als ob
grüne und fdp dann sein könnten wenn ihr
nicht dass mit geht was wir haben wollen
dann gehen wir eben zur union
das ist genau diese verhandlungsmasse
die man so zu sagen hat auf der anderen
seite ist das ja auch alles nicht so
einfach vor allen dingen auch wenn das
jetzt alles heute sehr harmonisch klang
zwischen grünen und fdp und auch in den
letzten zehn tagen darf man natürlich
nicht vergessen dass innerhalb des
demokratischen spektrums nicht diese
parteien doch am weitesten auseinander
gegenüberstehen und das hat man ja auch
den ganzen wahlkampf über gemerkt da
gibt es ja ganz erhebliche differenzen
darf dann noch mal vielleicht aus dem
wahlkampf zitieren da sagte christian
lindner statt auf der grünen verbots
orgel zu spielen müsse privates kapital
um privates wissen mobilisiert werden
und annalena baerbock antwortete die
klimakrise regelt kein markt denn dem
markt sind menschen herzlich egal die
frankfurter rundschau auch das noch mal
so schön zusammengefasst und an dieser
gegenüberstellung sieht man schon also
sind schon sehr prinzipielle
unterschiede in der herangehensweise
beim bewältigen der krise die da unser
künftiger regierung anzugehen hat und
diese diese unterschiede sind natürlich
auch groß also insofern ist es ja keine
homogene kein homogenes verhandlungsteam
das dann mit der spd an den
verhandlungstisch geht
insofern geht es darum für jede einzelne
parteien und auch das hat christian
lindner ja gerade nochmal gleich zu
beginn seines statements betont dass man
der eigenen wählerschaft natürlich auch
gegenüber
vertreten muss was man da verhandelt und
letztlich ausreichend der eigenen
inhalte dann letztlich auch in einem
möglichen bündnis wiederfinden würde da
wird gerne noch mal kurz darauf eingehen
jonas schreibt auf youtube mit der ampel
enttäuscht die fdp viele ihrer wähler
mit jamaika aber den großteil aller
deutschen wie groß ist da dieser spagat
den link märz leisten muss ja also in
den zweiten teil dieser einschätzung die
würde ich jetzt bei so daneben gestellt
lassen weil insgesamt ist ist die ampel
jetzt nicht so viel stärker was die
prozentzahl der wähler wenn man alles
zusammenrechnet
gegenüber jamaika sehr unterschiedlich
ist der trend dass es sich behandelt hat
sich halt drei wahlgewinner haben wir
zumindest wenn man die prozente mit 2017
vergleich bei den grünen muss man hinter
wahlgewinner wenn man die letzten monate
sieht vielleicht noch ein kleines
fragezeichen dahinter setzen aber
insofern würde ich das so eindeutig
nicht sagen aber richtig ist in jedem
fall dass die fdp es sehr schwierig
abend wird ihr klientel in einer ampel
ausreichend dann am ende sagen zu
befriedigen und christian lindner ist da
vielleicht auch gewissermaßen einer
zwickmühle 2017 diesen berühmten satz
gesagt es ist besser nicht zu regieren
als schlecht zu regieren dafür hat er
viel kritik geerntet und er wird sich
das sicher
sehr gut überlegen ob er das ein zweites
mal machen will auf der anderen seite
muss man sich halt die alternative
anschauen geht er in ein solches bündnis
und bringt nicht genug von dem durch was
im
im liberalen wahlprogramm steht dann ist
durchaus möglich dass die fdp auch sehr
gerupft aus dieser legislatur
hervorgehen wird da gibt es auch einen
gar nicht so weit zurückliegen das
historisches beispiel 29 bis zu 13 bei
die fdp ja auch in einer damals schwarz
gelben koalition und hat da sehr wenig
durchsetzen können zumindest nach
einschätzung ihrer eigenen
wählerklientel und und ist dann am ende
bei den nächsten wahlen abgestraft
worden
ich werde noch mal gerne auf diesen
druck eingehen der jetzt durchaus auf
der fdp lastet dazu schreibt ingo auf
youtube noch einen rückzieher kann sich
die fdp nicht leisten es sei denn die
fdp ist entweder nicht kompromissfähig
oder einfach nicht regierungsfähig das
ist ja das was du eben sagt dass nach
der letzten bundestagswahl
irgendwie muss die fdp ja diesmal für
sich eine lösung finden der exit option
gibt es ja eigentlich nicht das stimmt
man kann nach dieser lesart sagen ein
zweites mal
nein zu sagen können sich die parteien
nicht leisten aber dann muss man auch
die gegenfrage stellen kann sie sich
leisten
in ein ampelbündnis zu gehen in dem im
grunde das gegenteil beschlossen wird
von dem was im eigenen wahlprogramm
steht da ist die antwort sicher genauso
nein das heißt man muss schon darauf
hinwirken dass viel von dass das
zumindest nicht das gegenteil dessen was
man selbst den eigenen werden weil dann
verspricht dann am ende umgesetzt wird
und das sind ja diese gründen
schnittmengen die sind natürlich bei
grünen und fdp erstmal relativ klein
aber man hat ja versucht sie sie
auszuloten und es ist ja auch nicht so
dass es da nichts gibt ja insbesondere
ist da natürlich am spannendsten das
thema klima nicht nur weil es für die
grünen das wichtigste ist sondern weil
es ja die nach definition aller parteien
fast aller parteien größte
herausforderung
für die kommenden jahre ist und da ist
es nicht so dass
die beiden da nicht möglicherweise
tatsächlich so etwas wie common ground
haben also sich verständigen könnten den
grünen ist ja wichtig möglichst viel
klimaschutz durchzusetzen gemessen unter
anderem zum beispiel an den paris zielen
und die fdp hatte ja den
zertifikatehandel bzw dessen
ausweitungen ins spiel gebracht und
vielleicht ist es ja denkbar dass man am
ende so ein konstrukt
kreiert wonach der zertifikate handel
kommt und ausgerichtet ist auf ein ziel
das nochmal ambitionierter ist als paris
das wäre ja der grünen basis durchaus zu
verkaufen und die fdp hätte sich
sozusagen mit dem instrument
durchgesetzt also da gibt es durchaus
möglichkeiten auch wenn das natürlich
dann schwer wird das im detail wirklich
umzusetzen und eine zweite geschichte
ein großer knackpunkt ist ja die
steuerpolitik da sagt die fdp ganz klar
keine steuererhöhungen mit uns während
die grünen ähnlich wie die spd gesagt
hat wir müssen
stärkere schultern mehr belasten
auch hier gibt es möglicherweise
schnittmengen wo man sich zumindest
aufeinander zu bewegen kann die kalte
progression zum beispiel den der fdp
seit langem ein dorn im auge also das
sozusagen
wie eine stetige langsame
steuererhöhungen dadurch haben dass
jeder in der progression hoch rutscht
dadurch dass durch normale
geldentwertung sprechen über sprich
inflation man zwar eigentlich nicht mehr
in der tasche hat auch wenn es immer
leichte anpassung des gehalts es gibt
also diese kalte progression die seit
jahren von der politik zu
beklagt wird aber doch hingenommen wurde
möglicherweise wird man nie abschaffen
dann hätte die fdp auch da sozusagen ein
erfolg verbucht mit denen die grünen
leben können aber das ist natürlich noch
zukunftsmusik und ist dann sicher
gegenstand von ebendiesen
sondierungsgesprächen jetzt anstehen
weil daniel du bist ja schon so in den
themen drin das klingt ja fast so als ob
du bei den ersten gesprächen vor
mäuschen hätte spielen können
heute vormittag von einer stunde haben
die grünen er ist schon länger her es
war um 10 2 stunden ihre entscheidung zu
einer ampel bekannt gegeben und was
annalena baerbock gesagt hat und wie sie
die entscheidung begründet hat darin wir
noch mal kurz rein wir haben in den
letzten tagen bilateral mit
unterschiedlichen parteien gesprochen
mit der union mit der spd und mit der
spd immer respektvoll sachlich auch
konstruktiv und vertrauensvoll und das
sagen wir in allem respekt dass sich
alle parteien darum bemüht haben nicht
nur über trennendes zu sprechen sondern
gerade auch wie man brücken bauen kann
für gemeinsamkeiten nach diesen
gesprächen haben wir uns beraten und
sind zu dem schluss gekommen dass es
sinnvoll ist weiter jetzt vertieft
gerade auch mit blick auf die
gemeinsamkeiten die wir in diesen
bilateralen gesprächen feststellen
konnten jetzt mit fdp und spd weiter zu
sprechen und das schlagen wir der fdp
fort da in ein solches dreier-gespräch
jetzt gemeinsam rein zu gehen
genau sie spricht von diesen brücken die
du ja inhaltlich eben schon mal
angesprochen hast und wo du einige
punkte rausgepickt hast jetzt hat ihr
kollege josef harbeck vorhin gesagt der
drops noch nicht gelutscht oder er hat
gesagt ich denke es ist noch lange nicht
gegessen so was inhaltlich kommt glaube
ich auf das gleiche raus ist er wirklich
noch lange nicht gegessen oder
entwickelt sich da jetzt gerade so in
den parteien sonst berührt dass wir
wollen das und wir schaffen das und wir
wir machen es uns schon so dass es
passen wird
es hat sich ja schon relativ schnell
nach der wahl
ja diese dieser satz etabliert dass die
spd es jetzt eigentlich nur noch selbst
versauen kann weil sie sozusagen der
position ist und wenn man dieses bild
der poleposition mal aufgreift dann
glaube ich betrifft ganz gut also die
spd ist sozusagen die nun ihren roten
wagen in ihrem roten boliden vorne
unterwegs ja und dahinter sind sind die
grünen und die gelben und wenn die sich
jetzt nicht gegenseitig abschießen
sondern so ins ziel fahren dass am ende
jeder mit seiner punktzahl mit der er
mit seinem platz zufrieden ist dann wird
das eine relativ einfache sache und dann
wird der schwarze bolide von der cdu/csu
dann traurig hinterher fahren sozusagen
aber das hat man auch um in diesem bild
zu bleiben der formel 1 schon häufiger
erlebt dass sich die wagen dann
ineinander verkeilten sich gegenseitig
abschiessen dann am ende eben doch noch
mal derjenige nach vorne fährt den man
eigentlich schon abgeschrieben hat sich
glaub so wird so ungefähr ist dass jetzt
alle wissen um die ernsthaftigkeit der
aufgabe wissen dass das auch jeder auf
den anderen zugehen muss weil das in
jeder der genannten konstellationen der
fall ist ansonsten bliebe als einzige
alternative noch nicht schwarz-rot oder
in dem fall rot schwarz das will niemand
das haben alle seiten immer wieder
bekräftigt auch wenn es teilweise armin
laschet bei der letzten befragung nicht
ganz ausgeschlossen hat aber das ist die
unrealistische unrealistische option zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt ja und
insofern glaube ich sind da schon alle
spd grüne und fdp zielgerichtet am tisch
aber klar ist auch sie müssen alle ein
ergebnis erzielen mit denen sie am ende
auch vor die eigenen wähler auftreten
können bleiben wir noch mal bei dem bild
von dem traurigen schwarzen boliden und
schauen noch mal auf die union daniel
wass welche optionen haben die jetzt
noch können die kann die union jetzt
einfach sich zurücklehnen und schauen
was passiert ob die anderen gespräche
platzen um sich dann wieder ins spiel zu
bringen denn wärme auch gestern gesehen
nach den sondierungsgesprächen von
grünen und union dass diese charme
offensive von söder und auch wenn auch
etwas verhaltener von laschet überhaupt
nicht so wirklich gezündet hat ja also
genauso ist wie gesagt man sie sitzen
jetzt in ihrem wagen und müssen gucken
was die anderen da vorne veranstalten
und können im moment nicht so wahnsinnig
viel tun gestern bei der pressekonferenz
von cdu csu und grünen fand ich am
interessanten das atmosphärische in der
tat diese erkennbare charmeoffensive
gerade von markus söder bei armin
laschet fand ich interessant dass er
gestern
vielleicht sogar zum ersten mal seit der
wahl genau diese demut gezeigt hat von
der schon seit dem wahlsonntag oder seit
dem montag am tag nach der wahl immer
gesprochen hat die war ja dann in dem
was die union gesagt und gemacht hat
nicht immer zu erkennen genau diese
demut gestern schon da wirkt er so doch
sehr sehr defensiv und da zeichnete sich
glaube ich schon ab das was dann heute
verkündet wurde nämlich dass es erstmal
ampel gespräche geben wird kommt man
eben abwarten muss unions seit ich ob
man sich da daneben verhakt und dann als
union selber noch mal ein spiel kommt
und dazu natürlich immer noch das
sternchen sozusagen die fußnote
hinzugefügt dass die union im moment
selber mit sich selbst genug zu tun hat
und da einiges zu klären hat und
ja auch sehr unterschiedliche interessen
der einzelnen player innerhalb der
partei dazu berücksichtigen sind es gab
diese durchstechereien in den letzten
tagen die ja durchaus auch die
atmosphäre der gespräche beeinflusst
haben wobei natürlich da auch nicht ganz
klar ist von wem das kommt klar ist nur
es von ihrem mann dem der kein interesse
an jamaika hat denn das ist durch diese
durchstechereien mit sicherheit nicht
wahrscheinlicher geworden daniel sagt
zum schluss jetzt nochmal wie geht es
bei euch in berlin weiter wie ist jetzt
der konkrete fahrplan für die nächsten
tage noch mal im grunde sind wir hier
wird es tatsächlich seine
politischen echtzeit republik in diesen
tagen wir haben eben auch erst erfahren
dass während dieser pressekonferenz dass
es morgen weitergeht mit den gesprächen
von spd grünen und fdp und auch die
termine heute wurden sehr kurzfristig
terminiert insofern ist da für uns nicht
viel zu planen sondern dann auf das zu
reagieren und wir schauen natürlich auch
mit großem interesse was dann da morgen
möglicherweise schon bekannt gegeben
wird nach den ersten gesprächen dann
möchte ich mich bei dir bedanken daniel
johnston im hauptstadtstudio berlin und
danke dass du mit uns die
pressekonferenz der fdp begleitet hat
und sie mit uns zusammen eingeordnet
hass und auf den stand der dinge
geschaut hast was gutes und ich darf
mich auch bei ihnen bedanken für dabei
sein und ja ich wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen tag machen sie es gut